welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and now that we're meeting the Kang
Dynasty and the whole Council of kings
and quantumania and Marvel Phase 5
Beyond it's easy to see them as a
collective mass of screaming Mad Men
with a decentralized organizational
structure what I assume Tommy is
referring to when he says the bills
Mafia but the truth is as with any
Dynasty or any Council not all kangs
were created equal and there is very
much a hierarchy and a lot of drama so
I'm gonna break down the 12 kings that
we have met so far in the MCU explain
who they are and rank them based on what
we know about them from the comics but
more importantly how the MCU so far
seems to be casting them based on the
limited contextual Clues we've been able
to find and we're going to rank them by
how powerful each one is how deadly they
are how truly influential they are on
the rest of the MCU Multiverse so let's
do this every gang ranked let's get
cranked also subscribe to our new
channel the Deep dive where I did a very
detailed look back into Loki season one
he can support our our growing Network
by grabbing some merch and nerd
riot.shop like something from the deep
dive collection okay let's start with a
quick reminder of the kangs we have yet
to see who are not in the MCU yet but
may have pretty important roles incoming
titles so we got iron lad the young
Nathaniel Richards variant who breaks
good and leads to Young Avengers and
Kang Prime the all-powerful Kang at the
end of all time Whom The Avengers fight
in the Avengers Unleashed Kang War
storyline Kamala Kang who is able to
stretch herself beyond space and time he
got kid immortus a version of iron lad
who breaks bad a galactus-powered Kang
the Time Eater and dozens of more wacky
and awesome ones but let's look at the
12 forms of Kang who have been
introduced so far and rank them based on
how the MCU seems to have rescaled their
overall influence starting at the bottom
number 12 the timekeepers so the comic
time keepers are not kangs they're their
own beings who exert a greater degree of
influence over the time stream but the
MCU timekeepers are robotic puppets who
are used by Kang variant he remains to
maintain taking control over the TVA and
since the TVA is a secret to most of
existence the timekeepers are really
only as powerful as Miss minutes is
they're just really in office corporate
mascots to keep the employees motivated
but yes I do consider these forms of
Kang however as they are voiced by
Jonathan majors and one could argue many
kangs are disguises and masks worn by
other kings okay number 11. the
Nathaniel Richards is the scientists
these are the altruistic Nathans who
made first contact with each other in
the 31st century and shared their
resources described in he remains origin
story in the Loki season 1 finale these
guys don't seem too dangerous and we
have to assume many of these scientists
died in the multiversal war but some of
them may have survived to become the
deadlier Kings we meet later it's just
really impossible to know number 10
reptilian Gang This is a blue skinned
weirdo looking Kang that we see at the
end of the quantumania mid-credit scene
and I believe he actually might be the
reptilian King from Earth Mesozoic 24 in
which Earth is inhabited by intelligent
reptilian humanoids instead of humans we
actually got a close-up of majors in
this makeup and some Twitter photos and
I rank him low because uh really he's
just sitting in the cheap seats real
nosebleed section of the Arena so how
important could he be really he kind of
looks like one Kang's weirdo Kang friend
who he invited because he felt bad for
him but really equally on reptilian
Kang's tier I rank all the screaming
Fanboy kings in the stands I think there
is a distinction between the Kings and
the crowd and the Kings on the field
kind of like that SNL 40th anniversary
event being in the 8h studio audience
was an honor but if you didn't get stage
time you were trash okay so this brings
us down to the field you got dreadlocks
Kang we see this King appear briefly on
the right side of frame this guy looks
ready to brawl and I rank all the other
kings that we see on the field on this
guy's level we don't know if all of them
are that deadly but there is a reason
the others are cheering for them but
right up front and center is an armored
Kang maybe Doom Kang he wears black
medieval style armor which you could say
looks similar to that of Victor Von Doom
but it isn't really exact there is a
king in the comics who fuses with Dr
Doom an extremely powerful Force it's
just that we don't have much to go on
other than the Armor to conclude that
this might be Doom Kang but the fact
that he is so armored up one has to
assume he's pretty deadly okay I'm gonna
sneak in another one here number seven
Victor timely so comic rankings list
this Kang as one of the weaker kangs
since he was more of a common man a
Thomas Edison style inventor in 1901 he
didn't really get in a lot of fights or
Wars but I ranked the MCU Victor
timeline higher because he was not among
the other Kang summoned to the arena and
he's considered a high priority Person
of Interest by Loki and Mobius and if
Victor timely was the root of all
advanced 20th century Tech Stark Tech
pimtech Shield Tech and if he actually
did encode a Fail-Safe switch into all
of AI that he can control like he did
the Sentinels in the comics he could end
up being very dangerous and I think
right above him is another Kang we saw
in the field the recipient of all of
that tinkering Mr Griffin and I know
I've called the Mr Griffin in other
videos but it's just because I read his
name in the comics and I was like oh
it's Griffin and I had a Hermione
Hermione situation in my head but
anyways Mr Griffin and yes we did see
him or who I think is him on that Arena
floor wearing a slim suit he is the CEO
of Kang Enterprises who we're now pretty
sure is the one who bought Avengers
Tower as a present day MCU Kang with
control over the most recent Avengers
weaponry and Technology he is
essentially as powerful as all other
Earthbound forces in the MCU plus you
know he's got the power of timeline
manipulation now a lot of people have
given up on being good at sleep but it's
only because they don't realize what a
difference good sleep gear Makes You Can
level up your sleep game overnight with
Helix sleep Helix sleep makes premium
mattresses embedding customized to fit
your needs and shipped right to your
door and look I'm not a sleepologist or
anything but I don't need to be Helix
has a sleep quiz that matches your
unique body type and your sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you you can even take it with a partner
and find the mattress that is a perfect
compromise between your preferences I
took the quiz with my wife we wanted a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
that sleeps cool and now that we're
newlyweds we upgraded to a dusk Lux
Helix mattress can king size we just
unrolled it and you know what we
completely love it we're both sleeping
better we wake up less often than we
used to and again Helix delivers your
mattress order right to your door for
free it comes rolled up in a shockingly
tiny box and it's super easy to set up
yourself Helix has a 100 night sleep
trial so you'll get more than three
months to make sure that you love your
mattress and if you don't they'll pick
it up for you and you'll get a full
refund and these mattresses also have a
10 year warranty that's an entire decade
Helix even has financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great night
of sleep is never far away I love my
Helix and I think you would too if
you're looking for a new bed check out
Helix you can click the link below or go
to helixsleep.com new rockstars to get
20 off your Helix mattress plus two free
pillows okay number five Kang the
Conqueror aka the exiled one this is the
Kang from quantumania he ranks pretty
high because he started the multiversal
war from he remains story and it was
revealed that this Gang has the blood of
trillions of lives on his hands it did
something in particular to really piss
off the Scarlet Centurion however this
guy's also got some pretty big blind
spots he did allow his ship to get
sabotaged and he got overwhelmed by some
Advanced ants who broke his suit and
made it so that Scott Lang could hang in
there long enough for a Jake Paul split
decision however if we assume this Kang
isn't dead but just got trapped in a
probability storm we could even go as
far as to say he might be king Prime
someday now topping this King in my
opinion are the three who mutinied
against him and he could say that
one-on-one Kang the Conqueror could take
any one of them down but let's be honest
there are strength in numbers and the
ability to cooperate and form alliances
with other kings does elevate one's
individual status so here we have the
three that we saw in the mid-credit
scene but among these three there is an
internal hierarchy so number four on our
list Pharaoh Rama Tut this was the
earliest time Lord in Marvel Comics who
would later be retcon to be Kang he
appeared in 1963's Fantastic Four number
19 ramatut was a guy who used the Sphinx
as a time machine and ruled over ancient
Egypt we later learned to create the
fabled in sabanur aka the earliest
mutant on Earth apocalypse but he was
overwhelmed by the A Fantastic Four but
this Fair aromatite has an Android body
in his lower half telling us that he may
have had a different backstory Peyton
Reed has indicated that all three of
these guys aren't exactly the comics
forms but really versions of them nods
to them bringing us to number three
Scarlet Centurion Peyton Reed also
confirmed that this robotic Kang who
looks nothing like Scarlet Centurion is
their version of scarlet Centurion but
the Centurion is a form that Kang takes
after leaving ancient Egypt getting
caught in a temporal storm and taking on
a form that evokes Dr Doom so this
robotic suit may be what the MCU has in
mind for their Doom I kind of hope not
he ranks higher than Rama Tut because he
calls the other two when the exiled one
dies and unlike ramatai Scarlet
centurion does not bow to immortus so
number two on our list immortus he seems
to be the leader or the Elder of these
three while Centurion summons the three
of them and mortis calls the Thousand
others he seems to have insights into
the sacred timeline and the Avengers of
the other Stolt and in the comics
immortus was a appointed by the
timekeepers to watch over the timeline
from the various threats and to repair
the mess left by his previous
Incarnation and on the page he's often
considered one of the most powerful
Kings but not here in the MCU because at
the top of our ranking is number one he
who remains because while King the
Conqueror started the multiversal war
these three kings were unable to end it
they fell victim to him the only one who
ended this war was he who remains
because he was able to weaponize Elias
yes Sylvie did stab he remains but the
fact that his death Unleashed all of
this madness tells you how important he
was and is because I don't think we're
done with him and we still do not know
the full extent of his power it's
possible even that he remains is or was
one of the others on her list Victor
timely Mr Griffin and if so we will soon
learn how entrenched he was in MCU
history as he remains would have been
the one Kang who could still exist
within the sacred timeline as it was
previously written so until the exiled
one returns as king Prime I think we
will all look back and see he remains as
the devil that the others were the most
afraid of hey a reminder to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive and
support us by Grammys of merch at nerd
riot.shop you can follow me on Instagram
and Twitter at EA boss follow new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you